ننتقل الان خالد لابو ساميه وهو لحسن الحظ
لم يكن في المنزل حين انهار هذا المبنى
كان في المستشفى لتلقي العلاج هو يعاني من
اوضاع صحيه سيئه وبالتالي كان يعني بعيد
عن المنزل لكنه ايضا فقد بناته وزوجته
ممكن عمي ابو سامي اول شيء عظم الله اجركم
والله يرحمهم ممكن تحكي لي من فقدت انت في
الزلزال انا يا امي اخواتي تنتين
ابن اختي بنت اختي
زوجتي وبنات سنتين واخ الي
اعانك الله على هذا المصابه ابو ساميه في
انا عرفت انه عندك بنت ناجيه تحكي لي عن
وضعها وحكت لي انه عندها وضع صحي معين وهي
بحاجه لعلاجات بحاجه تشرح لنا عن وضعها
وكم عمرها عمرها 16 سنه هي العمر 16 بس ما
بحسب غير العقل
الها علاج الى اكل خاص كله العلاج يعني
والاكل الخاص كله غالي
طب بعد ما فقدتوا المنزل والبيت انت انا
زي ما فهمت انه انت كنت في المستشفى لمده
16 يوم لكن بعد ما فقدته المنزل الان انتم
وين موجودين نحن الان في بيت لكن هذا بيت
مين هذا البيت كان ساكن هون وهو اخ واب
وعيلتنا العزيزه يعني
قعدنا عنده هلا نشوف شو يفرج علينا
ان شاء الله شو ناقصكم عمي انتم يعني
كمتضررين
أنا بنتي هاي اني يعني
اطلبه انا عائلتي بالاردن الي عيله
واخواتي هنن بالاردن اطلب من جهات المختصه
بهالشغله انه تحاول تساعدني تطلعني على
الاردن مشان بنتي لانه ما بقدر انا كم اخ
لك في الاردن عمي
انت فقط كامل عائلتك هون فبالتالي انت
اخلص يعني ما ضل لك اشي هون يعني زي ما
بنحكيها يعني حابب تروح على الاردن عند
اخوانك المتبقين هناك كيف كان وضعهم كانوا
يتصلوا معك يتطمنوا عليك يحكوا معك كان
يطمنوا ويحكوا معي عادي اخ يعني
هلا حاب اني اتواصل اني الجهات اي جهات
تقدر تساعدنا نتواصل على الاردن انه نطلع
على الاردن
شكرا عمي ابو ساميه كما استمعت خالد هذا
يعني جانب من المعاناه والمؤساء التي
يعانيها المتضررين نتيجه هذا الزلزال في
كهرمان مرعش هم يقيمون في منازل احد
الاصدقاء الذي اواهم في هذا المكان كما
تشاهد وحتى هو مكان متواضع وضيق بالكاد
يتسع للعائله التي استضافتها هؤلاء
الاشخاص المتضررين هذا هو حال كل
المتضررين سواء كانوا اتراك او سوريين
موجودين او اي جنسيه اخرى موجوده متضرره
في كهرمان مرعش وفي باقي الولايات
المتضرره هناك يعني حاله من التكاثف بين
الاهالي والعائلات وبالتالي تقدم
المساعدات سواء كانت مساعدات من الناس
للناس والمساعدات المتواصله حتى الساعه
انا وحتى لعمليات الانقاذ وازاله الانقاذ
من السلطات وكافه الفرق والمؤسسات او
الجهات التي تعمل على ذلك خالد حتى هذه
اللحظه